I'm heading back to the prison where
arranged to meet branding expert Matt
kingdoms well thank you this is it
I want Matt to help me market the slice
to ethically minded consumers it's like
a slice
I would love a size yeah thank you it's
got to turn into volume I mean I think
that's what's missing really there
Gordon you've got you've got a product
and you know who's gonna buy it but you
don't know why they're gonna buy it
morning guys
yeah well Matt thinks understanding the
prisoner's life stories is vital to
getting the ethical message across
really I'm a professional nosy person
right I dig into what people are
thinking and why they're thinking it so
I want you guys to tell me everything
how many times in beginning so infer
your times 30 odd how old are you 34 34
not 15 years right I've had a very long
drug addiction from a very young age
class a drug from the age of ten so tell
me about this the work that you've been
doing with Gordon what's it done for you
inspire me show me I can do that when
you're taking drugs or finger ways of
getting it or duck no diamonds you get
it you left you left with nothing
you left with empty things you go fill
that and this is feeling it Anthony
Kelly has been clean for nine months but
many of the prisoners in Brixton have
serious drug or alcohol addictions
ex-soldier David Jones got hooked on
heroin after leaving the army this
course has made me happy inside makes me
want to get up for the morning makes me
want to strive to be someone to do
something you know with my life
I think this is an important thing I'm
hearing from you and it's important
behind bad boys bakery that this isn't a
sob story you think that people hear
from you mm-hmm they actually hear about
what Gordon saying is discipline hard
work you need hard graft yeah
doing something doing something for
yourself change making a change yourself
or my kids Brigade have made huge
progress former drug dealer Hasan or is
desperate to put his old life behind him
and resume contact with his family I
don't know if he was taken toward a
future net he didn't order future other
than that but honestly if I did put him
low-income apart fall I'm sorry and I
probably had a lot so is there anything
in what you've been doing here with
these guys
does kind of made you think about
whether you gonna be back here for a
fourth time or not I'm gonna prove
everyone wrong died basically it's not
true though what's your criminal it's a
criminally gonna to change your life you
know it's very moving
it's very moving hearing that it does it
does make me think you know that some of
your personal stories are very very
interesting and would be very
interesting as part of may be a part of
the packaging or a part of a part of the
message that went out Matt has already
come up with an idea from marketing
slogan I think there's something around
the idea of life changing taste is
powerful I think it's emotional
we might want to think about it on the
pack